in a DC universe the Justice League
consists of the world's greatest and
mightiest heroes pretty much everyone
knows how Batman Superman and Wonder
Woman can kick major butt in a 2017
Justice League movie Batman seeks out
Aquaman to join his team what can he do
more importantly who the heck is Aquaman
Arthur curry
Aquaman first appeared in 1941 s more
fun Comics number 73 he told a sea
captain his father was a famous undersea
Explorer who discovered the ancient city
of Atlantis alcaman learned how to draw
oxygen from the water and used all the
power of the sea to make himself strong
with training and a hundred scientific
secrets he became in 1959 his origin was
retold in adventure comics number 260
telling a Navy Commander his story it
was revealed his father was Tom curry an
ex sailor who lived by himself as a
lighthouse keeper one night during a
hurricane
he discovered a woman stranded on a raft
rescuing her he found out her name was
Atlanta they immediately fell in love
and had a baby they named Arthur at 10
months Arthur fell out of a boat and
could easily swim on his own when he was
2 he struck his head while swimming and
sank searching for an hour his father
found him underwater
playing with a turtle when sharks later
attacked the cove Arthur could easily
swim alongside them when Aquaman's mom
was on her deathbed she revealed the
truth she was from the sunken continent
of Atlantis her people adapted to their
watery existence and they could live
like fish Atlanta was banished from
Atlantis due to her a constant desire to
visit a surface it turns out Arthur
inherited her ability to communicate
with sea creatures and could become
ruler of the oceans and yet another
telling of his origin in 1989 Aquaman
was abandoned in the ocean as an infant
even though he could command a fish he
didn't feel as right to make them
sacrifice themselves for his meals
sohow command killed what he could catch
he later met Tom curry a lighthouse
keeper and learned a ways of man upon
Curry's death
Aquaman sought out the fabled city of
Atlantis in search of his mother and was
immediately imprisoned after years past
his mother eventually passed away
outrage Alka man used his unknown
strength to fight the guards and broke
out of the underwater prison on a
surface world he became part of the
Justice League and later returned to
Atlantis he still wore his prison
uniform as a symbol and was shocked to
discover his mother was actually the
queen of Atlantis with these various
origins we have touched on what Aquaman
can actually do we know he can breathe
underwater he does have incredible
strength his body is pretty much
bulletproof since he's able to withstand
the high pressure of ocean depths his
Trident is also one of seven powerful
Atlantean magical items as for the
talking to fish part that's not exactly
what he does Aquaman has stated that
fish don't talk because their brains are
too primitive to carry a conversation
what he does is reach into their mid
brains and telepathically pushes them to
help him out in the Justice League movie
Batman finds Aquaman in a small village
by the sea this isn't the short blonde
hair orange and green outfit wearing
hero we've seen many times this Alka man
drinks and seems to have some anger
issues we'll have to wait and see how
exactly his backstory is tweaked once
again for this interpretation for more
comic and entertainment news be sure to
stay tuned to games by and GameSpot
universe
you